woke democrats they have left their mark
and not in a good way but americans
clearly are paying attention what we saw
in virginia with glenn younkin in
education what almost happened in new
jersey nobody was paying attention in
the governor's race there that race
could have turned red believe it or not
new jersey and here we have myra flores
150 years finally it changes hands to
republican it's got to be replicated in
every state every district in the
country now republicans are publicly
targeting 75 congressional seats held by
democrats i expect that number to grow
now if i were leading the republican
effort for the midterms i would try to
put every race in every state in play
yeah i'd even put the new york
governor's race in play anyway here now
with more from her big win last night
congresswoman elect
myra flores uh congresswoman first of
all congratulations everything was
perfect in your video we've got to work
on that soccer kick a little bit i
didn't know soccer kick needed a little
help
no thank you thank you so much i
appreciate it
your family and your life story is
beyond compelling um a district that was
democratic for 150 years
now you're on the ground obviously
illegal immigration have been a big
issue
where you live
tell us
what changed what happened
well you know i was blessed to come here
to united states legally when i was six
years old and i want that experience for
all children i don't want any child to
have to go through such dangerous
journey so i'll never understand why the
democrat party continues to encourage
with their policies illegal immigration
knowing what they're going to go through
and i want to focus on legal immigration
and improve the the process where they
don't have to go through
that journey and look we don't have to
hear it in tv about the border crisis
it's happening here right behind our
backyard so it's very real to us child
trafficking is very real to us and
children are innocent no matter where
they're from and it they should be our
priority
so your parents came here legally like
my four grandparents came from ireland
uh legally and they came through ellis
island
we see something happening we always do
polling in election years and we break
things down demographically what we've
been witnessing is a dramatic shift
among hispanic american voters
african-american voters
the youth vote in particular
women voters are out there they're all
leaving the democratic party at least on
paper for now we've seen a few political
earthquakes i would argue
yours your race is a huge potential
bellwether for what may happen in in
november
why do you think that people in
demographics that historically have been
in the democratic party or the
democratic party coalition why are they
now leaning towards the republicans and
conservatives
well i feel like the democrat party has
walked away from the hispanic community
they've gone so far left and they don't
represent our values people always ask
me myra how can you be a republican
whenever you were born in mexico and
that's that clearly shows me that they
know nothing about our culture i was
raised with strong conservative values
we're all about faith and family and
hard work that's who we are so our
values do really align with the
republican party but i do feel that you
know for a long time prior to 2020 no
one was really paying attention to the
hispanic community and i'm grateful that
finally the republican party is
investing in the hispanic community
because we are the future but the
democrat party has completely abandoned
us and taken us for granted they feel
entitled to our vote and they feel they
don't really have to work for it and
what we're showing now is that yes you
do have to work to earn our vote and
that's why we won this special election
because we worked hard we knocked
thousands of doors made thousands of
phone calls i have the most hardworking
team and that is the reason why we're
also going to win that re-election in
november because no one is going to
outdo the work that we're doing
well and by the way elon musk voted for
you i'm kind of fascinated with elon
musk i think is a great modern day
innovator uh and and a really
he's a real true original to me uh
what'd you think of that
i was honestly so excited when i heard
about it and i'm
so grateful that he came here to south
texas and invested in this community
because again this community is amazing
we're all about you know family and hard
work and finally you know so many people
are like ellen musk are coming here to
invest in this community and i will
always be grateful to him and in spacex
and i can't uh wait to to meet with him
and have an opportunity to tell him you
know what the plan is
district 34. you have a you have clout
now you are the elected congresswoman
the sad part is you got to run again in
november i understand it in a redrawn
district uh we're going to follow your
career very closely we congratulate you
uh congresswoman thank you for being
with us hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else